hi everyone i'm hoping you're all
feeling well and safe these days my name
is nicholas and i'm pleased to present
my joint work with my hairdresser one
word bloom here in 90 cs 2020
our pattern is called small circuits
imply efficient automatic protocols
and in one very high level sentence
it talks about a new connection between
circuit store bonds and protocols that
are called automatic particles
but this is a very high level
description so i would like to start
with the automatic abstract that will
describe what exactly our petal is about
so to unstack sucks let's get started
so our story begins with two main
characters we have artem which is going
to represent a limited resources machine
that tries to solve some problem
alto must be efficient but he is allowed
to interact with merlin which has
infinite computational power
and the catch is that smelling is
non-trusted it might be malicious so r2
must analyze the information that is
provided by merlin in order to verify
that melanin doesn't try to fool him
lucy speaking this actual the main idea
then out to melbourne particles
the first character in our stone is
called the dnf of parties which is a
boolean circuit that consists of a dna
from the top of the circuits and the
layer of parity gas exhausts a below
just below the dnf
and lastly the four character is the
binary inner product function
our purple talks about a connection
between these four characters and
specifically we focus on open culture
and circus complexity that asks whether
dns parties can approximate the inner
product function
entire results says that a positive
answer for this question
gives to a very efficient automatic
protocols to a wide collection of
problems in two models the first model
is called automation cache complexity
model and the second model is called
automation data streaming model
and the interesting thing in our results
is that the resulting protocols are
actually at least from our point of view
there seem to be too good to be two
which immediately leads to two
conclusions the first conclusion says if
we agree that there's only protocols are
indeed too good to be true
then they can serve as an evidence for
why the answer for this open question
should be negative
the second conclusion says
okay i don't know if fighting main lower
bound is an easier task but
theoretically if we define any lower
bound on one of our resulting particles
then i will get the desired lower bound
on the uniformities for approximating
the inner photo function
and it is the right place to put some
disclaimer
so finding a lot of balance in
automation cash complexity or automation
data steering models
isn't exactly a considered as a
difficult problem
but there is actually lower bound on a
slightly different model that is called
outdoor main holographic entirety proof
and there is an apparently doubt is
because in the construction of our
protocols
we actually first construct a
preliminary protocol in the holographic
interactive proof model and just then we
derive from it a multiple particles in
these two concave complexity and data
streaming models so it might be also a i
understand a direction to consent and
think of
so in a much a little bit much more
details our paper shows that if we
assume that there is a polynomial size
dean of parities that computes the inner
product function correctly on more than
five over six function inputs
then we get out to very efficient
automarine strain protocols and
automatically complexity protocols for
for a kinds of problems
a all right so that was a dominant
abstract about what our father is about
and what i want to do now is to explain
why why we are focusing on approximation
while we are asking whether adenosphere
is can approximate the inner product
function
instead of asking where the idea of
parties can compute exactly
the inner product function
and the reason for that is because in
the case of exact reputation the
question was already been solved and the
answer is negative
and actually we knew that answer already
in 1997.
so the next question says okay we cannot
compute the inner product function using
a polynomial size dnf of parities but
maybe we can just approximate it
and by approximation i mean to compete
in a product function quality only on
most inputs rather than all of them
and even that this question seems to be
similar to the previous question of
exact computation
we actually don't know the answer in the
case of approximation
so currently this question is open
and
it's actually a little bit annoying
because at first glaze it doesn't clear
why lower bounce in the case of
approximation
is a much more complicated than showing
lower bounds in the case of exotic
computation
but maybe surprisingly all the known
techniques for six level bounds that
work in the case of
computer of exact computation
i started backing down here in the case
of approximation
so intuitively
maybe
solving harvard and progress in the case
of approximation will give us a better
understanding about general circuit
surveillance
and that was also a our goal and our
motivation
behind her work
so a
in order to be able to talk about the
exact quantitatively formal version of
our results we first need to
go over some necessary definitions
so let's start with a quick recap about
boolean circuits so a boolean circuit is
a directed acyclic graph that represents
a computation of some certain boolean
function we have nodes gates in the
circuit that each one of them computes
some elementary function of its thin
going of bits that it gets from its from
its in-going edges and then it follows
the result by its outgoing edges where
the result or the output of the entire
circuit is defined as the output of the
circuit at the top of
the output indicator of the gate at the
port at the top of the circuit
uh we also have two complexity
parameters we have the depth of the
circuit which is defined at the left or
the longest route from an input node to
an output node and where the size of the
circuit is defined as the number of
nodes the number of gates in the circuit
we also need to define what are these
elementary functions so we have the end
gate which takes the end of all the
simple bits we have the o which takes
the whole of all its simple bits we have
the note which takes a single input bit
and physics value
and we have a parity gates accelerates
which takes the parity takes the saw of
all its input bits
so we know what boolean circuits are the
next step is to define what is the dnf
authorities so then if part is here
there to circuit with the foreign
structure
in the first layer we have only so we
have only priority gates and then above
that we have a dnf so basically we have
a layer of particulates then layer of n
gates and then at the top we have a
single or gate
so a we know what is the inner part
parties and what i want to do now is to
take a zoom out and to discuss a little
bit about what is known and what is
unknown uh about the relation between
the abundant circuits and the endocrine
function
so let's start with ac 0 circuits which
are constant f circuits that use only n
o and not gates
and actually already from the 80s we
know that with these circuits we cannot
compute or approximate the parity
function which is a special case of the
inner product function so in particular
we cannot compute or approximate the
inner forward function using test
circuits
a material circuits don't use power to
guess at all so we have also ac0 with
parties which are again conservative
circuits but now they have oh and not n
parity gates
and with this circuit actually a very
easy to configure the inner product
function so let's see an example so the
inner product function it basically
takes a product between bits in x and y
ed when we take and then we take in
excel so the product can be done with a
single layer of ending bits of n gates
and then xo can be done with a single
exo gate
so without power tickets it is hard to
compute the inner product function
but with power to get is very easy so
the next question is what happens if we
allow the use of particulates but they
can but they can be used only on the
very first layer of the
and this circuit is called a c zero of
parities
and about these circuits we actually
don't know to say is a lot about whether
we can or cannot compute in a product
function
we do know some a weak lower bounds in
the general case or some strong global
bounds by in some splitted cases so for
example we know a struggling bound when
the number of parties is restricted to
something like a linear
but we don't know a stone glow bound
in the general case
and lastly we have the dna of priorities
with as i mentioned before
we know that
polynomial siding of quantities cannot
compute the inner product function but
to know that result only for exact
computation we don't know what happens
in the case of approximation
so what we're going to do in the rest of
this talk
first i'm going to describe our formal
quantitative version of our results in
the data stream model and that which of
course will be right after we will
define what are exactly how how to
maintain particles
then we'll do the same but in the
chromecast complexity model and after
that i will try to give you some
technical intuition when our results and
lastly in the last part we discuss about
some open problems that are related to
our work
so let's start with a data stream for
model and in that model we are going to
first uh define what is automation data
stream particles
and then we will see the quantitative
formal version of our results in that
model
so a in order to define what are out
domain data stream protocols
uh which are going to be an interactive
variant of the traditional model we
first need to define what is the
entirety of
so interactive proof is a protocol that
between two parties we have the verified
auto which is limited in resources and
we have the professor merlin which is
infinite computational power but it
might be malicious and it could be uh
and the protocol they proceed as follows
so the verified approval exchanges some
messages and at the end the verifier
needs to decide whether it accepts the
input or rejects the input
where we have two correctness properties
we have the completeness properties the
property that says that if x is in the
language then the verifier accepts the
type probability and the soundness that
says that if x is not the language then
no matter what approval does the
verifier rejects with type probability
and we also have something that is
called public target proof or also a we
call it a auto mailing intelligence and
in that a and in ultimate target both a
the verifier also have to center the
approval or its random coins and
immediately after they were told so
basically
in this type of protocols we can think
about the verifier messages as
consisting of only fresh random quotes
all right the next step is to define
what is that system protocol so in the
traditional letter strain model we have
only one party which is unbound anytime
and is required to compute some target
function f
we have unlimited time but we are of the
following two restrictions
first we must use only a small amount of
space and in particular only a
sub-linear space
second we don't have the full access to
the input instead we had the input as a
sequence of bits that is called a stream
and after reading submitting the
sequence we can no longer read it again
and yes of course where we stored it in
the memo
so uh we define what is data streaming
model and what are our two main
interactive protocols and what we are
going to do now is to combine two these
two models together and we will get
automated data streaming protocol
so
our two merlin data stream protocol with
a parameter
is a protocol that works in two phases
in the first phase although the merlin
exchanged k messages where the messages
that are two cents are consisting of
only first random coins
then in the second phase r2 gets the
input as as a stream and by running a
deterministic stream computation it
needs to define we need to decide
whether to accept the input or reject
the input well again we have the
completeness property and the strongest
property
and i want and i want to emphasize a two
points about these models
so the first is that i want you to
notice that in the second phase that the
second phase of the protocol is fully
deterministic
so basically during the entire protocol
auto is not allowed to have any private
coins at all
and the second point i want to emphasize
is that our tools is the input bits only
after the interaction to merely if not
before
and the reason i emphasizing these two
points is because there are actually
many variants of string protocols that
are that use some untrusted a powerful
prover that are different by such kind
of settings
all right so now we can talk about the
formal quantitative version of our
results in the same model
so we assume that we have a dean of
parties that approximately in a product
function to a factor that is greater
than five over six
and we get efficient automation with the
data stream protocols for two kinds of
problems the first one is actually all
the problems that are computable by low
degree polynomials and the second is a
compared problem that's called the party
triangles problem but first thing first
so let's start with the first problem
so our first result says that if we have
dnf of a polynomial-sized uniformity
that computes the inner product function
to a factor that is gathered then five
over six
that approximately the inner
professional factors is greater than
five of six
then we get
another main data stream protocol with
the rounds of interactions for every
boolean polynomial with total degree d
where the equivalent at the space
complexity i'll cross the linear with
the total with with the total degree and
logarithmic return will end the number
is the number of input bits that the
polynomial gets
so it is our first results and
just to give you some a
quantitatively intuition about the
efficiency of this protocol i want to
consider for example the case that the
degree d is a constant
so if the if d is constant
we get a constant around a protocol with
a constant a number of ones
and a performance space complexity that
is logarithmic to 10.
however if we will use a deformed
subject protocol then we'll get again a
constant number of fonts but the
complexity is going to be something like
n to the fact n to the factor of of 1
divided by n
so a by by simply a assuming that we
have a polynomial side then of particles
that approximate the inner product
function
we a can we we get an exponential
equivalent to the thermal synthetic
particle
so that was our first result our second
result a is a in a problem that is
called the parity triangulus problem and
the parity triangles problem
we have a graph which is vertices or all
the number between 1 and n
and the input to this problem is
actually the edges of the graph and the
goal is to count the parity of the
number of triangles in the graph
so i result in the party triangles
problem
is that they again we assume that we
have permanent side unified is boxing
the important function and we get
a automated strength protocol for the
party targets problem
where the number of phones is only one
and the performance and the
spectroplasty are fully logarithmic to
10 will end with the number of vertices
in the in our graph
so a that day was our results in the
town in the task in the data streaming
model
and now i want to discuss about the
communication i was attribution
complexity model and i'm going to skip
about the formal definition of what is
automatically complexity so
you guys can think about it as they
basically taking a standard chromecast
complexity model but the parties first a
random public coin interaction with some
untrusted powerful proven and just then
running a standard cache complexity
protocol
so a let's go to our results in that
model so in the chemical complexity
model we construct two protocols one for
low degree polynomials and one for
language for the languages that that are
decidable by constant depth circuits
so let's see the first result so
again we assume we have the nfl parties
that approximately in a border function
to a factor that is gathered in the 506
and we get automatic complexity protocol
with one round of interaction
where the concussion complexity is
logarithmic with the number of monomials
of the polynomial
and if we take for example upon male
with a totally killing then the chemical
complexity becomes to a d times logan
where n where b is the degree of the
polymer and then is the number of bits
the paranormal guests
and i want you to a notice that in
construct to the
call for polynomials that we got in the
streaming model
which had the rounds of interaction
here we only have a single round of
interaction
and actually it is very useful because
it let us extend our results
to a protocols that a
that also can a
decide any language that is decidable by
constructed circuits
and we it's and we do it by using a a
known technique of smolensky
that convert constant depth circuits to
polygon logarithmic degree polynomials
and then we basically use these results
so by using the osmo and smallency
techniques we get our third character
our four results which says that if we
have small dna of parity that
approximately important function then we
also have a automatic complexity
protocol with one lone interaction
for every language that is decidable by
constant depth circuits where the
communication complexity is polygologic
with a
the size of the a acco of the constant
epsilon
all right
so uh that was how results and in the
few minutes that we have left i want to
give some basic intuition about the
constructions of our protocols
so
we have four kinds of protocols in our
work
uh and actually all these four protocols
are based on some preliminary protocol
which we build first and then from it we
a construct or a we derive all our
and the preliminary protocol is going to
be a protocol of a special type of
interactive roof system that is called
holographic intelligent force so
algorithmic both are basically very
similar to interactive posts except that
the verifier doesn't have direct access
to the input
instead you have an oracle access to an
encoding of the input via some lineal
code
so we also have a new complexity
parameter which is called the curio
complexity which is the number of cubes
the verifier max to the linear encoding
of the input
and we have a new a denotation so by am
ajt
we define the outdoor merlin or the
public coin version of photographing
interactive work
well k indicates the number of messages
that are exchanging during the protocol
so a the flow of the construction of our
protocols actually goes as follows
we start with some assumption about dnf
of parties that can approximate in the
product function
and in the first step we construct a one
round out to main holographic protocol
a that verifies in a product lines
and this part is actually the only part
in our work that directly use the
assumption about the dnf parties
all our order four protocols
are actually a going to be built from
the holographic protocol and does the
use the assumption about the inner
parties only implicitly
so i kind of like before when i said we
have four kinds of protocols because we
actually have
a five kinds of
i want to focus a on a the protocol for
the holographic protocol for the product
lines
uh because this is the part in our work
that connects between a boolean circuits
and interactive particles
so what we are going to do now i am
going to give you some intuition of how
to construct horror graphic interactive
for inner product lines with one out of
interaction
a form the assumption that we have small
dna fighting that approximately
important function so first let's see
the formula a lemma
so the formula say that if we have
polynomial side d of parity that's
approximately a power function to a
function that is greater than five over
six
then we get a
out domain a one-round out-domain
holographic interactive force with
logarithmic curves and portland
a
that can verify any in a product line
and since we are going and since we are
going to construct an ologic interactive
both i also need to tell you which
linear code we are going
literally called our holographic verify
is going to make its cures
so the linear code we are going to use
is actually the output of the party
layer of the dnf authorities that we
assume that exist
so the first layer the particular of the
nf authorities is actually consisting of
only sockets so its output bits can be
considered of some linear combination of
the input bits so we can think about it
the output bits of the a parity layer as
some a part of some
encoding of the input bits via some
linear code so our orographic verify is
going to be
is going to make you
to the a output bits of the um
of the parity layer of the gene of
parties that we exist that we assume
that exist
all right so let's build a our protocol
a and as a walmart they actually going
to build a protocol that it doesn't work
uh but it would give us a a good
intuition a
for how the actual protocol is going to
work and also going to help us to a bit
later the actual working protocol
so we assume that we have at the small
line of parties that computes the new
product function correctly on most
inputs
so the approval can simply send an index
of a certified clause a certified gate
in the circuits
and the verification can be done by
simply reading the entire circuit the in
dental clouds and checking that is
indeed satisfied
so the preference is good the preference
is there is logarithmic
in the size of the circuit so we like it
but the equivalent complexity it might
be a large because the cure complexity
is depends it is equal to the
size of the clauses and no one can and
no one can promise me that the closest a
is not a very high very large
and we also have another problem and is
that a our protocol
only works on the average case because
we
start with with the circuits that can
compute the number product function
correctly only on most inputs
so we get a protocol that can verify
only inner products lines on most of the
inputs but not all of them
and moreover our protocol can only
verify whether in a product is equal to
one but it cannot verify whether our
inner product is equal to zero
so we have a these two problems in our
protocol i don't want to fix them
so let's start with queer complexity
what we are going to do is we are going
to reduce the complexity by making some
pre-processing a on the circuit
and in that pre-processing we're going
fails to reduce to remove all the white
clouds in the circuit and then after we
remove all the white houses we are going
to want a
that protocol and because where the
circuits a will no longer have a big
losses the current complexity is become
to a small if you come to logarithmic
so let's see it
so since it's clause a is an end is an
end of output bits of the parity layer
then each clause is actually a system of
linear equation of the inputs
so before we
removing the white clauses we're
actually going to first eliminate linear
dependencies within each clause and only
then we will going to remove a white
clause
so by making these two modifications by
definition
we get a circuit with the only
logarithmic size clauses uh so if you
run the a protocol that we saw in the
previous slides we'll get a protocol
with only which we're complexity that is
only algorithmic which is a required
but as you may might suggest
a you might guess a keystone
modifications also introduced someone
a the good thing is that they were
written that they introduced only a
small amount of pharaoh and that is
because we moved only white classes
and only clause that in each one of
these clauses it actually defines a set
of many independent linear equations
so each clause we move
actually adds a only a
2 to the factor of minus 100 log s a l
to the circuits so by taking the union
bound we actually ask only a 2d factor
minus 100 l to the circuit so also we
only add a small a
arrow to the circuit
okay so what we achieved so far we
achieve a protocol that have it has the
a the required complexities
but it works only on the average case
and it can only verify whether in a
product is what is one it cannot verify
whether in a product is zero
so we want to convert this protocol to a
protocol that can verify
any inner product lines
and the first
to area is is to use
a something that is a call that we refer
to as a the self-correction property of
the inner product function
so since then the product function is a
linear in each one of texas we can
actually get the form the following
identity
where note that if we take v and u as
random then then the terms in the right
hand side of this identity are called
the random inner product values and
that's great because we have a protocol
that works in the average case
so we can instead of asking for the
profile by the value of the original in
a product line we can ask the program
for the values that in the right hand
side of this identity we can verify them
with hyperability in our average guest
protocol
and then we take the solve the results
and get the results of the original
inner product line
so it seems a permission but the problem
is that it still doesn't work
and that is because a average case
particle can only verify whether or not
the product is one it cannot verify
whether an end product is equal to zero
so if the process a tells us that one of
these dams is zero
our vfl can't verify it
so a we still want to use the
self-correction property but we want to
find a way to detect also when the
prover sends a false zerocline
when the prover sent
says that something is equal to zero
when actually equal to one
and the way we are going to do it is by
default into observation
first i want you to note that the
expectation of the real values of these
random correlated terms is that index is
the expectation of the inner product
function which is roughly enough
the second observation is that since we
can verify with high probability all
that a all the inner products that are a
claims to be one then if merlin lies
with high probability he must lie only
by saying that some parent is that
that's some term here is zero and
actually one but it cannot do the
opposite because we have protocol that
can verify it with high probability
so basically it approval lies then the
average value of its claims is reduced
compared to the real values so the
average value of the approval claims is
actually different when the approval
lies and when is honest that means that
we have some statistical
gap between the cases and we actually
can detect it by simply running the
protocol multiple times
each time with a different random a
we we with a at a different randomness
we are going to verify
only the clients that only determines
that the verify that approval claims to
be one and we're going to blindly
accept all the terms that the proverb is
going to a sales that they are equal to
zero
but at the end of the protocol we're
going to check that if the average value
of all the claims that approval sent to
me are a
either close enough to the average value
of the inner product function
of the expectation of the inner product
so it is the a high level outline of the
construction of our graphics protocol
phone product lines
from now on is actually a only a some
technical statistical analysis so i'm
going to skip it
all right so now which to the last part
of our talk and in this part we are
going to discuss a little bit about some
open problems that are related
to our work
so the first problem is actually a the
anoint five of a six limitation
over the approximation of the dna for
parties so i remind you
all our protocols are constructed by the
assumption that we have adding of
parties that computes the inner product
function correctly on more than five
over six
fraction of the inputs
and the five over six actually came
from the use of what we call do as a the
safe quotient property of the inner
product function so an interesting thing
to do is to study whether and how we can
push this a
fa this constant is a five over six
function
a to something that is called to a the
conjecture
has a plus epsilon approximation
a also the second a direction it might
be interesting a to be able to construct
protocols for zero circuits a also in
displaying model so currently we know
how to construct a particle for the
cells that gets efficient protocols for
the circuit for sso circuits only in the
chemical complexity model so it might be
interesting to do the same also in the
strain model
also it might be powerful if we will
find a way to construct efficient
protocols
for the nc1 class a whatever it is in
the data stream model on the computer
complexity model or even in the
holographic interactive proof model
a and the reason that it might be
interesting is because they are actually
the lower bounds
a
auto main load balance
a 4 and c 1 a
and lastly of course we have the golden
goal which is a showing a second slow
bound showing that the enough part is
a cannot or maybe can i don't know a
approximately in the product function
so a thank you for listening that was
our paper small circuits in play
efficient automation particles